- cut - that's the conversation here all
right and we got each of the elements of
those additions that were made by the house in
its action yesterday incorrectly every instance
we have expressed to the Senate committee a desire
for a rehearing on on those matters where changes
were made some of the changes we did accept and
will proceed on the change basis in other words
you have a use for some of the money but not all
of it we are saying that we wouldn't have use for
all of the money that has been granted to us
by the house augmentation it's just that our
judgment is that at this stage of our research
and development programs on some of these more
modern weapons it does not seem to us that it
would be wise to proceed any more rapidly than
has been proposed by us originally of course
if the House and the Senate in its in its own
wisdom decides that it wants to grant us still
further fun we have just that much more flexible